[Music]
King Kong made a huge splash when the
movie character first appeared on screen
back in 1933 and he's remained a part of
global pop culture ever since showing up
in sequels and big-budget remakes over
the decades but his latest incarnation
puts the giant 8 somewhere both new and
familiar right here in New York City
Jamie Wax went behind the scenes at one
of this season's most spectacular shows
Jamie good morning cannot wait for this
good morning Dany the headliner of a
Broadway show is often referred to as
the top banana or the 800-pound gorilla
both of those terms most definitely
apply to one of Broadway's newest and
biggest stars although in this case it's
actually a 20 foot tall two thousand
pound gorilla the Broadway musical King
Kong is the latest retelling of a story
the world can't seem to get enough up
since the original movie versions
premiere in 1933
King Kong has inspired multiple remakes
sequels
related projects and guest appearances
in the films of other famous movie
monsters the 2017 quasi reboot Kong
Skull Island even spawned a sequel of
its own due in 2020 I think every
generation gets the bond they deserve
the every generation gets to King Kong
they deserve
od Henderson reviews and writes about
movies for Roger Ebert calm he's a
lifelong fan of the original King Kong
tale in all its various tellings I think
you can identify with it if you didn't
belong anywhere if you felt that you
were out of place
that's the allure of King Kong is that
he is the great giant outsider who's
come to this major town and causes a
sensation he's not just an animal you
know he's kind of become somebody that
you can look at you know and have some
empathy for and we see our own personal
growth in him right I always said it was
a New York love story
that point isn't lost on Kong's current
Broadway leading lady Christiani Pitts
when I first saw him I cried a little
bit because I couldn't believe that that
was my scene partner and my co-star and
it took me about 15 minutes of silence
of just sort of walking around his body
and to just really let it sit in that
I'm going to be forming a relationship
with him for the next year of my life
and it was overwhelming because he is so
magnificent I mean it's technology and
creativity at its finest like the
creature himself this song was born
across the sea before making his way to
New York City the puppet is a marvel of
Technology and stagecraft it contains 16
micro processors that give Kong lifelike
motion and emotions his chest and abs
are constructed of airbag like materials
and his limbs are made of high-pressure
inflatable tubes to bring Christiaan his
co-star to life takes a team of 13
talented performers 10 on stage
and three creating the colossal puppets
larger movements facial expressions and
voice from a glass boom at the back of
the theater this is a beast that's
inspired by legend and also in
forward-thinking theatre technology drew
Marconi is the show's director and
choreographer he uses a microphone to
communicate with his team members in the
booth there's a moment in the show where
and touches his face and he you can feel
genuine love and kind of almost mournful
kind of aside from him
he reaches out
[Music]
I will tell you standing here watching
that it's impossible not to be in awe of
what what it's capable here
I think everyone's expecting the scale
and the kind of epic nature of him but
that nobody's ever really prepared for
the emotional capacity of the beast the
thing that absolutely punched me
squaring the soul was when you look into
the eyes of the Beast and he has got
this amazing kind of liquid depth within
his eyes you can almost see yourself
reflected within it that aspect the eyes
maybe the key to the characters
connection with audiences those eyes are
phenomenal and they're deep like a human
being they're beyond belief King Kong no
matter what version you watch the one
thing you notice about King Kong is the
eyes and they say the eyes are the
windows to the soul so you watch King
Kong and I matter what he's doing
whether he's destroying things that he's
looking at whatever actress his eyes
he's there something behind them while
many critics loved the production even
those who wrote mixed reviews heaped
praise on pizzas performance and the
artistry and execution of Kong himself
if you come and see King Kong on
Broadway you will leave a part of
history because this sort of technology
has never been introduced to a Broadway
stage it's not only the technology
that's making history but also its
herself what does it mean to you to be
the first African American actress to
play this role in this iconic story for
a lot of people of color there's always
been this sort of disconnect with the
story that some people could pinpoint
and some people couldn't I know myself
as a little girl I loved it and there
are moments that made me feel really
weird and uncomfortable and I couldn't
figure out why until I got a bit older
and I noticed some sort of racial
undertones that the story is carried but
I think right now women all over the
place are sort of gaining this newfound
power and speaking up about what it
means to make your own decisions and and
it's so unique because she knew this in
the 1930s this is a this is a black
woman who in 1930 decided to say I am my
own woman
no one can tell me otherwise have you
had connections with younger fans
especially younger women of color or
little girls who have been inspired by
what you've done yes and it makes me a
little emotional to talk about so I'll
try not to tear up but oh sorry it's a
beautiful thing to see little girls who
look like me who want to do this so bad
because I know what that feels like to
to want to be someone of so much
importance but feel like you aren't
actually enough to be that and here you
are Here I am and we should point out
that that wonderful actress Christiani
Pitts is the daughter of one of our
former colleagues here at CBS Byron
Pitts really well back in 2003 she was
like a little sprite all of this
incredible just joy about her and it's
so wonderful to see it so king kong
can't sing or dance but it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter you know people
are talking about different things about
the show it's worth seeing it's a
spectacle you don't want to see King
Kong play George and Sunday in the park
with George thank you